here while digesting I'll try to stay
entertaining so that you don't fall
asleep um what I'm going to present here
is about a problem that is called direct
access in database uh in the database
Theory uh community and this is join
work with mydent Oliver Inn so let's
start by giving you a broad introduction
to what is this direct access problem
for what I call join queries so you have
already seen this kind of slides since
you're here so I will be a bit quick
about it but I think it's good to put
the context again so I will be
considering join queries that is
conjunctive queries without existential
quantifier right I don't have any
existential quantifier here and this is
like you have ATM each atem corresponds
to a table and you can basically
conjunct this atem which is a join
operation if you look at at a more
applied uh database point of view so
let's say you have a table with people
living in cities and a table that tells
you which cities are capitals then you
can join them and basically you end up
with the people living in European
capitals here and the thing I will be
interested in about here is that this
andet of the query uh I will order it
lexicographically on this order induced
by The Columns here so City Country ID
name so I will always write conjunctive
query in order I want them to be
lexicographically ordered right and the
direct access problem is very simple
problem you have given a query you are
given a database and you want to
simulate an array access to this answer
set of the query so basically what you
want is that if someone is giving you an
K you want to answer with a K stle of
course provided that you have order Q
with this lexicographical order right so
let's say that you want to access QD of
force the four solution of Q on database
D this is Franchesca living in Roma in
Italy
right okay so what people have been
interested about uh in this room
actually and in this community is to
solve this problem in two steps first
you allow some
preprocessing and then you want to
actually answer any direct access query
so you any K can come to you and you
want to be to ently solve it so one easy
solution to do this is you start by
Computing a huge table that contains
every solution of of Q and obviously you
sort it with the order that you're
interested in and then whenever someone
ask you the K you just output the K
through right this is simple yeah but
the pre-processing here is a bit
expensive yeah possibly this is be the
forms the database to some polinomial um
of the query which may be too expensive
in
practice of course the answering da
queries step is quite cheap this is
basically reading a row and outputting
it so here I do not say this is constant
time because somehow you have to write
down the bits of the answer so this
let's say this is polog in the size of
database because you have to write down
the answer and this you don't have a
constant number of bits this number of
bits depends on the domain of your
database okay but you can say this is
constant if you prefer right it just
depends on the model of computation that
you are using all right so can we do
better basically can we have better
preprocessing without sacrifice yes if
you fix the query this does not no
because I mean you still have to to to
write down things that are in your
domain and you need log log of the size
of the domain bits to write down this
thing
right I mean let's let's say your domain
is Berling Germany all these values that
appears here I mean if you want to write
down Berlin you need at least this
number of bits and this is related to
The Domain of your database it has
nothing to do with your
query okay but if you don't like it just
say this is biger of one but I I prefer
to write it don't like this because
actually your results and the result I
will be talking about we also have a
polog uh time access and this is a way
of saying you do not lose much by having
a polog Time access because this is
actually what you have even in the dumb
array uh technique
okay right so you can forget about this
just compute the table sort it and
answer the k r right and remember that
this is expensive to do because you
don't want to compute the whole table I
mean this is expensive to compute this
whole table so can we have a better
preprocessing without of course
sacrificing sacrificing uh the direct
access
phase right
so it turns out that you can and this is
based somehow on a class of queries that
is well known because there are some
classes of queries where we know that we
can decide whether the answer set is
empty or not in polinomial time observe
that on a very general in a very general
case in terms of combined complexity
deciding whe whether you have an answer
or not is inp hard right so but we know
some classes of queries where this can
be decided in polinomial time both in
the database and in the
query so we will look at these classes
of query as good candidates for the
direct access uh problem of course I
mean if you want to solve direct access
you need to solve this problem first so
let's look at the classes of query that
already enjoy tractable model checking
this is called Model checking right okay
this kind of results it generalizes well
for counting the number number of
solution to the database and as I will
talk about it to this direct task so
this is a very interesting class of Cent
so here I put a lot of names because I
will be talking about many papers in a
mixed order just saying a lot of ideas
so these are people who contributed to
the things I will be talking about I'm
trying to be more precise in the rest of
the talk when I'm mentioning a precise
results but sometimes this is just an
imprecise comment and I don't want
these people to be
forgotten all right so what is the class
of query we will be interested in today
I'm just looking at some part of the
story I will generalize later but let's
look at this a cyclic queries so maybe
you are familiar with it already but
let's do a quick recap so this is a
central class of joint queries in the
literature and I will explain to you how
we Define them so let's start from a
joint query so you have eight at terms
and each at mention a subset of
variables so what you start to do is
that you write down the variables of the
ATM in bags you put them on your paper
and then you try to draw a tree between
this bags of variables right okay this
is simple if I do not add condition you
can always draw a tree connecting this
bag I trust you that you can do that but
what we will be interested about is some
kind of connectedness condition meaning
if whenever I look at a variable let's
say I'm looking at x and I looking at
all the bags that contains X then I want
this tree to be connected I don't want
hold in my 3D composition so here you
see that every bags containing X are
blue and they are connected
by same thing with Y we have a sub a
tree a connected tree that contains
every bag that contains y so if I can do
that with my conjunctive query then my
conjunctive query is a cyclic and this
is called a joint tree and if you are
familiar with database you can think of
a joint Tre as some kind of query plan
some kind of order to evaluate your join
your your joint query I will go back to
it in a few
slides okay so let's have a look at this
algorithm that helps you to decide
whether the answer of an ny conjunctive
query is empty or not so I'm starting
with this and then I will progressively
go to the direct access
problem right so you start from the
joint Tre you have an iycc query you
have a joint Tre so start with it now
you load data inside the joint Tre so
you replace this YT by some Bag where
you have put the actual table of your
relation here right so you have data
it's nicely tied out in a tree and now
we are going to exploit this three
shaped structure to decide whether Q has
a solution or note and we will do some
bottom up computation on this tree by
filtering out couples in this figure so
you will look at every Edge in the 3D
composition in this joint Tre from a
bottom up manner so let's look at this
Edge this right edge here I'm deci
trying to decide whether the tles here
could be
extended with some tle that is here
below that is connected here and you see
that one 1 Z you can connect it to one
one and to one Zer Y and V here V does
not appear here so you have just have to
look at the v as at the Y variable and
one one Z you can connect it to both
tables here and 212 you can also connect
it to both Tes but the one three Z1 the
zero here for the Y value prevents you
from connected it here because here y
has to be equal to one so this tle that
I put in red you you cannot extend it to
a to a temple that also satisfy this
table that is also in this table right
so you know that in your joint query
this one you can forget it it will never
give you produce a solution of your
joint query so you just Dro this one and
you do it for every Edge so if you look
at this Edge you can see that the
remaining tles here can still can all be
extended with a tole here so you don't
do anything same here and if you look at
this here you realize that this tole
20 uh cannot be extended to any tole
here because uh here Y is equal to zero
and here you need y equal to one uh so
you cannot extend this so you have
removed tole from from this data
structure and now how do you decide
whether Q has a solution or not you can
simply reconstruct the solution of Q
from this data structure by reading it
top down basically the invariant that
you have is that for any tole that
remains at the end of the computation it
means that I can extend it below to a
solution and this is true for every tle
that remains in the end so let's say
that you want to extend this one one one
you know that you can extend it with one
one zero on the right and to one one Zer
on the left and to one zero here and to
one zero here and you get a solution of
Q here right so to decide whether you
have a solution or not you just need to
basically take whether it some temper
remains in each bag in the end of the
computation and that's some form of Y
algorithm it's not exactly how it was
presented originally it's not how you
can the best thing the best way of
thinking about it but this is the way I
will need in this talk so basically you
are filtering some solution and then you
you have some invariant that tells you
that you can
reconstru and this algorithm you can
actually Twisted it so that instead of
just deciding whether you have a
solution or not you can count the number
of solution and instead of filtering a
topple you may just remember how many
way you have to extend this tole below
so this is just changing the summer ring
for those people in love with summering
here I'm one of them uh so but basically
you can tag each tupple so that you know
that this one one one tupple here it has
you have two way to extend it to a full
solution below and you can do it in a
bottom up comput the same way that we
did it for for the model checking
problem so you can count the number of
solution of QD and the nice thing that
you can do is that you can use it to
actually solve some kind of direct
access
query and I I I'm going to be quick
about it because this is not the whole
purpose of this talk but just to give
you an idea on how um the algorithm
works is that let's say that you
want uh to Output the solution in this
lexicographical order XY z t UV it was
not chosen randomly this this order
somehow is chosen accordingly to the
Joint three that we have here I will
talk to it about it later but let's say
that okay you want to Output the third
query the third solution for for sorry
of Q on database D so basically we start
by looking at the value you need for X Y
and Z and this value I mean you know
that if you take 111 you will extend it
to at most two solutions so you don't
have enough solution here you need a
third one so you need to go to the next
row where you have solution and so you
have to pick two one zero for XYZ and
then you can do it recursively by
twisting a bit of parameters but you
just go down in the tree by changing
what is the solution you are looking for
and you set variables this way and in
the end you have constructed the thir
solution I will not dwell into details
but that's the idea you use this number
that tags eurow here to access the third
solution and what has have been shown by
CIS K and Ral basically is that if you
have a conjunctive query a joint query
that is a cyclic it's not written I
cyclic because somewhow I twisted it
something but let's think of it as a
cycli query and you have an order X1 xn
that is compatible with your joint tree
let's wait for a bit for what it means
then you can answer direct access
queries with some pre computation that
is linear in the database and polinomial
in the query so this is good for
Combined complexity right and once you
have done your pre computation you can
access it in poly log of D so that was I
was rambling about polog in my first
slide because somehow you do you haven't
lost anything on the access time but you
you have improved uh the prep processing
by by much I mean you are linear now in
the size of the database instead of
being D to the number of variables of Q
or something
related right so and basically this is
the algorithm I've shown you uh you just
need to understand what is compatible
order but basically from a compatible
order you build a joint Tre and then you
do the yanaki stuff that I have shown in
the previous
slide right so what is a compatible
order here then a compatible order is
actually very tightly related to the
notion of I cyclicity in hypergraphs so
let's say that you have a nice cyclic
hypergraph
here and you all know trees right if I
give you a tree and I'm ask you is it a
I give you a graph and I ask you the
question is it a tree so how would you
solve it one way of solving it is to
look for cycle right this is what we
usually do but another way of solving
this problem is that you take the tree
and you remove leaves right and if you
can remove leaves until the tree is
empty the graph is empty it meant that
this graph was a tree you have exactly
the same phenomenon when you look at
hypergraphs and related aity Notions for
hypergraphs so the acyclicity of
hypergraphs that I've been talking about
in my previous slides can be
uh defined as some kind of leaf
elimination of what I call an alpha Leaf
an alpha Leaf is some X such that the
neighborhood of X that is everything
that is in an edge with X so this is the
green part of the picture here is
included in some age e of the hypog
graph so if you look at X in my picture
then here is is its neighborhood in
green and this is included in the red
age so this is an alpha leaf and you can
remove it and if you can remove Alpha
leavs until you get an empty hypog graph
it meant that the hypog graph was Alpha
Cy and this is characterization a
cyclicity for hypergraph so let's say
for example look at this hypergraph here
you can remove one because the
neighborhood of one it is one two three
and this is included in this Edge so you
can remove one then you can remove two
you can remove three and then you can
remove four observe that you could not
have started with three because a neot
of three is 13 4 and you have no age
that covers 1
okay so this is some kind of leaf
elimination characterization okay and
this characterize Alpha acyclicity so
this is the acyclicity that I've been
talking about with this joint tree you
have many kinds of acyclicity in
hypergraph so the one that is usually
called acyclicity by database people is
the alpha acyclicity so I'm starting to
call it Alpha acyclicity because in a
few slide we will have another
acyclicity okay so you have this
characterization of alpha acyclicity in
terms of elimination order it has been
called another wizard disruptive Trio by
uh NOA nichas Fang M and Benny in their
paper but
I prefer this Alpha elimination order
because it predates by several decades
uh this def the definition I mean has
been known for for the 70s basically um
so yeah let's use this Alpha Leaf
vocabulary
here right so let's reformulate uh the
theorem if you have a conjunctive query
and if xn X1 so be careful here you have
to to reverse the order if it is an
alpha elimination order of your hypog
graph of the of the query basically um
then you can answer direct access query
with this pre computation and this
access time this is the same theorem I
just change what is a compatible order
into some precise
definition so what is the algorithm
schema of this how do you prove this
theem so basically you take the order
you construct a j tree that is
compatible with your order and then you
load the data you annotate the toos oh I
the way I've shown you with this yanak
is modified
algorithm and then you use this top down
reading of the of the tree to answer
access direct access
qu right so this this is not my
contribution right I mean I'm only
talking about the work of other right
now
yes so the query you are assuming is Al
is there any so if you have an alpha
elimination order then it is Alpha
cyclic by definition so you cannot avoid
this but I mean if you take any Alpha
elimination basically you can measure
its complexity and you will have a to
the K here if the complexity of the
elimination is K yeah I understand it
correctly that you are saying that query
is Alpha if only if if only if this kind
of elimination order exist does not
have you disruptive Trio as yes this is
this is yeah this is the same but this
disruptive Trio has been called Alpha
Leaf before I mean this is a
characterization of acyclicity that is
related to the GF characterization of
alpha cycli hypog graph this is
something that has been around for a
long time
actually this is just that people are
used to understanding this Notions
through the joint tree uh which is for
the direct access problem not the right
way of seeing it and actually this would
I mean I'm picking a bit on the
vocabulary but this this was very clever
from
uh I'm sorry I will not repeat your your
name all the time but for in your paper
this is really the same this is really
the nice idea of characterizing this
this kind
of all right so what am I talking to you
about this I mean this is not my work
right so let's let's change a point of
view here and let's actually connect
with the the topic of this uh Workshop
which is a circuit approach to this
exact same
results well so it has been explained to
you by amet actually that if you have um
some a cyclic conjunctive query then you
can build some kind of factorized
database that represent the answer set
of the query and basically Amed hasn't
told you exactly how you construct it
but you can see it as some kind of
modified version of yanakakis where
instead of annotating things with number
of tles you annotated it with caragen
product decision gate I mean Etc you I
mean you build some some circuit in a
top in a bottom up fashion this is
exactly yanakakis way you change the way
you plug it it don't worry if you can't
read it I will not use this circuit but
this is just to illustrate that
basically you can reconnect the temples
with some circuit gase and in the end
you get a factorized database the same
that ammed was mentioned this morning
that basically computes the answer set
of the conjunctive and this circuit is
very nice because you can do any sort of
thing uh and just recall what Amed told
you this morning get count enumerate
project existential quantification can
do many
things right so what you get here you
can also see it as a decision dnf for
the people that are fond of dnfs I mean
he has many names and this is one of the
of the Annoying Thing with circuit this
it appears everywhere in many disguise
but okay let's focus on this and some
property of this circuit that has been
not that much exploit to to this day is
that you actually have a bit more on
this so here is circuit I will called an
order decision circuit so I'm just like
simplifying the terminology here because
I I don't want to to say most full
letter each time I I change the slide so
this is some kind of circuit so whenever
you have a variable that labels a node
you decide which value you will assign
to your variable so let's say here I
have X1 I can assign it the value zero
and then I need to assign it a value to
X2
Etc and sometimes you have also
cartisian product meaning that if I
assign X1 to two then I will do the
cartisian product of the solution below
and the solution here so let's let's
draw a picture so for example this tle
here X1 is zero X2 is zero3 is z and
four fire one you it is witnessed
somehow by this pass in the circuit I
mean I x 1 to Zer then X2 to Z X3 to
zero X4 to one X5 to one and I reach the
top gate and accept I accept this top
right same with this temp here
2221 I start by assigning X1 to two and
then I reach cion product gate so now I
try to go below both branch of my
cartisan product and now I have X2 I set
it to two X5 I set it to one and here X3
to two and X 4 to one and I reach top
gates in every uh descendant of my Cen
product so I accept this tole and this
is a this is the tle the way this tle is
represented in the CC so this circuits
represent all the tles that you have
here you can check you can find some
kind of witness for every tle on the
right this is what you have seen since
already three days so it should not come
as a surprise but what is interesting in
this structure this is what actually
Amed Amed talked about a bit this
morning is that you have some kind of
order on the variables and any pass that
you take here follows this order so if
you look at the Red Pass then you test
X1 X2 X3 X4 X5 in order if you look at
this part of the blue pass then X1 is
tested before X3 that is itself tested
before X4 and in this way X1 is tested
before X2 that is tested before X5 so on
every pass you respect the
order right and what is interesting here
is that you may
inter uh the variables I mean you have
X3 X4 here X2 X5 here so this is this is
not your cartisian product does not
dominate one side and another I mean
here you have you have some zigzag
between the variables but you don't care
because this they are not on the same
path so what is important is that if you
take a path you have to follow the the
variables in the in the right order
right okay so what can you do with
this okay this is what I was saying you
can inter variable
sorry question yeah what are the the top
and bottoms on Lea yeah so top means you
accept bottom means you reject yeah
sorry yes I should have mention so like
if you take X1 is one oh no like zero
zero zero and two then you reach a
bottom gate and you reject this one is
you will not accept this I see so so you
need to top gates to accept it yeah you
could also represent it by just not
having any Edge going out of your there
are many ways of representing in just
picking yes
think it is nod with conjunction yes but
but you have to be clear on what you
mean by the fact that your conjunction
ordered because this is not the same as
ordered dnf where everything on the left
dominates everything on the right I mean
you may enjoy live and this is important
for the
result yeah this is an OBD with end
Gates this is yeah this is one of the
other bit in the alphabet soup of
knowledge compilation yes yes yeah then
so when you see a product product how do
you how do you Trav what's the order of
traversing the oh it may be many order
you just need you just need that if you
take a pass in this dag you you need to
be order right and you Traverse them any
anywhere you want just just you don't
care you Travers cardan product but this
pass here it should be
ordered okay so if you look closely at
the yanakakis based algorithm I have
shown you one slide one or two slid
before it should roughly construct this
kind of structure as long as the order
here is compatible with the joint Tre
right but you can also have another
point of view by running some kind of
DPL on new query directly and this will
also Al gives you an ordered circuit so
basically DPL uh you can see it as this
algorithm so you want to express every
answer of Q on database D then you can
say this is every possible D I plug X1
to Value D and I look at the answer of Q
where X1 is equal to D on database d
right so you inductively compile uh you
decide the value of X1 this is a
decision gate right and then you
recursively compile this new conjunctive
query with where you have plugged X1
Tod and the other optimization that you
need is whenever you encounter a
conjunctive query that is DEC composable
that is cardian product Tak the name
that you like that basically says this
is the conjunction of two conjunctive
query that have this variables then
basically you know that the answer set
of Q This is a cardan product of q1 and
Q2 not too hard to figure out so
basically you do this induction so you
say okay I'm compiling this I'm deciding
on X1 whenever I see a decomposition
here I add a Carden product and you do
recursive computation so you build a
circuit reive recursively right and of
course you maintain a cache if you have
seen a query already you do not
recompute it you store it in a cache and
you just plug uh to the gate that was
Computing this the query you had seen
and if you look at the trace of this
algorithm this is exactly the circuit
here that I've shown you provided that
you follow the order whenever you pick
the next variable to to De this this is
just another way of building this kind
of circuit but this will be handful uh
in a few
minutes and what you can show is that uh
if this is an alpha elimination order so
if this is the order that was tractable
for uh for direct access then basically
this algorithm cing and just you just
remember what you have computed you look
at DEC composition and you just plug the
variables following the alpha
elimination order then this gives you a
circuit that is linear in the size of
the database and polinomial in the size
of so I mean this is a stupid algorithm
you can you can impl implement it uh and
you don't need a joint Tre or anything
this is the beauty of this you just
remember what you've already done and
naturally The Joint tree will kick in at
some point but you don't really need to
see it I mean
the elimination order
is okay so what it means is that if I
have a a query q and an alpha
elimination order I can build the
circuit for any database okay this is
just rephrasing what Amed told you this
morning and the nice thing here is that
on this kind of circuit you can now
solve direct access so if you see me
coming what we will do instead of using
this y based algorithm we will build a
circuit and answer d direct access
queries on the circuit directly instead
of using the
joint okay so how do you solve direct
access uh queries on this kind of
circuit so I took a smaller circuit to
illustrate you will have a
precomputation phase that is polinomial
in the size of the circuit where you
will tag every decision gate by a small
table so this decision gate what you do
is that you tag the Zero Entry of the
table by the number of solution of the
circuit
below where X3 is set to a value smaller
than zero so here if you set X3 to a
value smaller than smaller or equal than
zero you have one solution so you put
one here now if you set it to one you
look at the number of solution you have
when you set X3 to a value that is
smaller than one so this is either zero
or one so you have two solutions here
and now if you set it to two
then this is not a solution so you have
two Solution on in this gate that extend
X3 with a value that is smaller than
two okay you do the same for every
decision gate that are connected to top
and bottoms and then you go up in the
circuit and you do the same like if X2
is set to a Val value smaller than zero
that is
zero you have two solution because
basically this is a solution of this
circuit and this circuit has two
solutions now if you set it to a value
that is smaller than one either you can
go through this Edge or this Edge and in
any case it produces two solutions below
so you have four Solutions Etc so you
can you do this kind of bottom up
computation and you end up with this
table that tells you if I fix X to a
value smaller than one here it means
that I have 10 solution below and this
is the same thing as what we were doing
on the joint Tre but we are just doing
this on a
circuit okay and now how can you solve
direct access queries on this circuit
let's say you want to find the seventh
solution of this circuit in the
lexicographical order induced by X1 X2
X3 so you find the seventh solution so
you you start by choosing the value of
X1 what is the value of X1 I have to to
choose if if I choose something that is
smaller than zero then I don't have
enough solution because I only have four
solution that are that set something to
zero but if I set set it to one I have
10 solution so I know that if I set it
to one I will find the seven solution
below so I know the value of X1 and I
can go down in the circuit I have found
the value of X1 for the seven solution
must set X1 to one
actually and now you have to recurse so
you have to find the value for X2 but
you do not look for the seven solution
anymore because you have forgotten about
four Solution by not going down here so
you have to remove this four solution
from your pool and now you look at the
third solution of this subcircuit and
you do the same the third solution you
have to force X2 to be one and you
recurse and in the end you know that X1
equal 1 X2 equal 1 X3 equal 1 is the
seventh solution in your Cas right so
far this is the same algorithm what
happens when you have cartisian product
so let's say that you are looking for
the certain solution so now you have to
hit X1 equal 2 because you need
something that is greater than uh 1 okay
so I fix X1 to two but now I have a cion
product so I will go below the cardion
product and I will reach two decision
Gates and know I hit the gate that is
labeled by
X2 and I need to find the third solution
because I forgotten 10 solution here so
I need 13 minus 10 I'm looking at the
third solution but of this purple uh
sets of decision Gates and the third
solution here you have to be careful
because if you look at the table of
X2 there is no third solution right but
this is forgetting that you have a pool
of solution here you you can set X3 uh
in two different ways so basically the
number of solution that X1 X2 here you
have to multiply by two and you know
that you have to set X2 to two and with
the same reasoning you go down and set
X2 to three so basically you maintain
some kind of Frontier in the circuit and
you set each variable one after the
other and you find the X solution uh in
the Lex Lex graphical
order and deciding what is the value D
here okay here you only have three
values so you can just go over the whole
table but you can do a dichotomic search
here because you see that this is
ordered I mean the greater the value the
the most number of solution you have
because because you look at the number
of solution that have
a value smaller than two so you can do a
dichotomic search here so designing the
next value is always polylogarithmic in
the size of the domain so basically what
you have is that you have a pre
computation that is linear in the size
of the
circuit uh and the circuit was linear in
the size of the database but then
whenever you are doing rank access query
then you are logarithmic in the size of
the domain so you have the
same uh complexity bonds but instead of
having this algorithm
schema where you use a compatible joint
Tre Lo the data blah blah blah you
construct the circuit you annotate the
circuit and you use Tod indiction to
answer access queries and now I will
have to rush a bit because this is just
an change of point of view of the same
algorithm but is it I mean why why why
am I bothering this is the same
algorithm basically I just swap The
Joint Tre for a
circuit it is not exactly the same thing
because in a joint tree you have this
extra un Ling three structure so you may
not see it in the circuit but it's there
I mean if you even if you compal from
DPL you will have this three
structure um and actually we can show
that you have small ordered
circuit that if you impose this three
structure this is the tructure of dnf
for those who who know you will blow up
the side of the circuit so basically you
can represent more things with this
older circuit than with the Drone tree
approach okay this is more powerful
because you don't have to to have a tree
you just need
orders and actually this is uh witnessed
by this uh results that I will not talk
much about because I'm running late but
basically if you take a conjunctive
query that has negation in it we know
that this is not tractable for the alpha
cyclicity the cyclicity of databases the
one I presented before but what happens
is that you can trade this acyclicity
for another acyclicity that is called
beta acyclicity and a beta cyclic
queries is a query where every subquery
is Alpha
cyclic and you can characterize it in
terms of elimination order and you have
this result that tells you basically
that if you take conjunctive query with
negation and an elimination order that
is good for this beta cyclicity notion
which is a restriction of the alpha cyc
notion you can build a circuit and this
circuit has polinomial size in the
database and then on this circuit you
can solve direct access queries so
basically it gives you direct access
algorithm for conjunctive query with
negation and you could not have proven
this using the joint approach because if
you look at this paper that I've written
in Le in 2017 I show that representing
this kind of answers in a circuit that
is structural along a tree is
exponential size so you cannot use a
joint Tre approach in this
case right uh so let me just wrap up
quickly basically the same technique uh
works for sign joint queries where you
mix positive and negative atoms you just
have to adap the notion of acyclicity
that you are using and I haven't talked
about existential quantifier but
basically you can build the circuits By
ignoring them and then project
everything in the end as long as you
project from the bottom of your
circuit okay uh and you can also
generalize it to a notion of width that
is basically the fractional hyper
through it if you look at the positive
case but that sits between B cyclicity
and B hyper through it if you look at
the negative case okay thank you for
your attention and sorry for the rush in
the
[Applause]
end
questions um so it's clear that the only
orders that you can support are those
that are what you call compatible with
the a cyclic hyper graph but in many
cases I
mean the hypergraph that you have might
be quite H arbitrary I might root it
right I mean I can root it in any way so
what if I want a different order what if
I want to give weight to the tles and so
uh how do you I mean do you have any
hardness results for orders that are not
compatible with
the with joint Tre or other polom time
results so yes so for the for the
positive case so you have this result
byan Mel and car bringman which
basically says take any order and you
can measure its complexity uh Vis A the
query so let's say okay this order has
hyper is related some hyper 3D
composition of with K and you will have
to pay a preprocessing d to the K and
this they have fine grain lower bond in
this case so basically you can you take
any order and you can know what will be
the worst case of this order if you pick
the wrong database
basically uh for the signed one we still
have no lowens this is work in progress
what do you mean by signed queries so
queries with negation so this one that I
shown you with B
cyclicity the contribution that I was
presenting today basically um you need
uh we don't have l so we don't know
whether we have the right definition of
the complexity of an order I mean this
is still a bit
mushy so is your circuit more flexible
than uh the factorized database that AK
showed us so can you achieve achieve
better compression with with this than
factorization so B yeah yes yes for bety
ques for example this is this is what
I'm saying um if you take a beta cyclic
query with negation then basically if
you do the algorithm presented uh by
Amit that roughly use a joint
threee then you will blow up
exponentially you need to forgot about
the threee structure and because you
have some you may have different
subquery that behaves differently VAV a
joint Tre so you need different joint
for different subquery basically so if
you enforce a joint tree at some point
you will reach a subquery and you will
just explode because this is not the
right joint three but if you just try to
maintain the order it will work but then
basically I never know what they call
factorized database they have so many
different uh classes of factorized
database so basically I would not be
surprised that they have one uh
definition that roughly matches this I
mean Hamed this morning was talking
about order but it does not appear in
the original paper of done he told me
that this is a new insight in the
circuit this that looks like my insight
so I guess this is basically converging
at some point so but yeah if you enforce
the free structure whatever I can tell
you is that it is
this will broke thanks but you can call
it factorized database to this is
exactly the same this
is uh I just want to make this uh
comment about Connections that uh I
think you know about it but uh all the
these types of concept were uh
introduced also in constraints and we're
bored from database the notion of joint
Tre and the joint when you have the and
this algorithm that you describe
yanakakis algorithms it can it's simply
a variable elimination algorithm so it
can be generalized to to summation to
optimization to constraint satisfaction
to
enumeration uh going from bottom up by
um variable elimination what you
described can be yeah but then this is a
top algorithm if you do variable yeah
it's a it's a bottom up and then you can
do it also top down so I this was not a
contribution this is not a contribution
it's just to change a point of view
because I know that people used to
database theory always do this bottom of
construction from The Joint tree I agree
and it fails miserably when you have B
basically this to change I agree
completely and indeed in constain
satisfaction you don't do this because
you could to find the solution you go
from bottom down but this operation are
called our consistency just making
connections uh and there the question
one question is when the database is not
a cyclic so do you embed in an acyclic
database and do the and no so basically
if you have a let's say this is not a
beta elimination you just pick some
arbitrary order on the negative joint
query then basically the complexity of
this order will be the worst subquery so
you take every subquery and you say what
is the worst complexity for this order
on this subquery which is roughly the
worst hyper truid induced by this order
and this gives you the complexity of
solving this order I mean you can
generalize it to a width and then you
will just
increase uh the polinomial that you have
here I mean you will have bad degree so
basically it's not really interesting
for practical
purposes okay uh so um the last comment
is that there is exist this class of
queries finding the M best Solutions in
the context of uh uh graphical models
and I there is
some work about how to find the embest
on a Le through the composition I think
there is some relationship so it could
be yeah but is not exactly n best I mean
here you need a direct access so you you
need to no it's not the same not exactly
the same but there is it seems to but I
mean you can solve the N best problem in
in here too yeah okay thank
you I guess um there how does this
relate to uh can you you should be able
to generalize results to the approximate
variant where you want not the cas but
it's a Yeah so basically I believe that
I could approximate the number of
solution of this class of circuit
because you know this is nice you can
fix the variables in order yeah and it
blew up in my face because basically you
may follow cartisan product in different
ways if you do different choices and
somehow you have to maintain a Frontier
where you have different decision
variable I mean you cannot adapt the NFA
algorithm for this and I was almost sure
I could until the day I realized that no
you need some there is some
combinatorial explosion somewhere I can
elaborate on it on the Whiteboard if you
want but I'm not claiming it is not
approximable I'm just saying that the
naive generalization of shop NFA does
not work what I'm saying so despite the
fact that it looks like it should
work so you okay just so that I
understand it properly instead of asking
K solution I want a solution that's
within like K into 1us EP to K into 1
plus epon oh no this is not what I I
believe okay for this but I mean you can
solve the K problem directly so why
would you no no uh can we look at
broader class of
queries yeah I guess we can but I have
no idea what would be the right question
to and I think the good starting point
would be positive queries because they
behave in a better way than negative
query which is related to sat in a way I
mean this is more complicated
than
yeah so you mentioned that
uh uh for different subqueries for
specifically for queries with both with
both positive and negative atoms for
different subqueries you use different
geometries what do you mean by
subqueries in this context okay so uh do
I have yeah so look look at this query
like you have this is Alpha cyclic I
mean you have triangle but it is
contained in a huge hedge so from the
point of view of positive queries this
huge Edge constraints the value of one
two three into something that is
polinomial so you don't really care to
have a cycle inside here but now imagine
this is a conjunctive query with
negation and let's say that the atem
here is negated right yeah and in your
database the table is empty so the
subqueries are like the positive uh no
this is this appears in the negative
case because I mean let's say this is
negative yeah you it's and and you take
the empty table so this is just like you
don't have the edge I mean if you have a
negated empty table this is like the
table is not here right so here are the
subquery is what you have on the right
yeah so subquery here you you end up
with a cycle and then your techniques
based on Alpha city does not work
because basically you have killed it I
mean this this cannot be trable because
this is not a cyclic anymore okay I will
catch up with you later Regarding why we
need different subqueries yeah actually
I need to catch up later for the FAQ
queries also related to this so may
similar so I'm trying to distill there
seem to be two separate claims and I'm
trying to get my head around these two
things so so the the first claim is you
Doak is in a different framework and one
claim that I think Onan also made before
is that somehow the circuit perspective
is more elegant this is something I
would like to understand more because I
have not seen this and I think also
Reena shaking her head because the joint
Tre seems to be simp similar the second
argument is that you can do more things
and you've shown us here an example but
it seems there an ongo discussion that
actually with a change of perspective
one can actually also capture them in
some other way can you explain us the
first thing the argument that also Anan
made that somehow the circet perspective
like rephrasing yanak kakis in the
circuit perspective is more elegant I
think this was one of the claims can you
help us understand why why I I didn't
see this from was how to read from the
but is the can intuition why I I don't
want to to enter into aesthetic argument
but um basically
look when you do yis right
uh
okay so I've shown you you can do Y for
the model checking fine then people
figure out oh I can do yis for constant
delay numeration then people figure out
oh I can do y for model
counting and this is always the same
algorithm basically I mean you are doing
bottom up induction on your de
composition but one way of seeing this
is just saying oh I can do uh
compilation with yis and since I know
that on this circuit enumeration
counting model checking weighted
enumeration everything is tractable then
basically you have one dirty algorithm
that uses joint Tre but you you have it
once and then all the rest this is so I
don't understand this argument this is
all of these are just different semi
rings of dynamic programming you count
or you make the Boolean version why so
you're saying that somehow all of these
arguments when people saying an account
H is now with counting they are
different algorithms I don't see this no
this is a same algorithm this is this is
three four papers across three 30 years
basically um so something's happening I
mean this is not that easy to go from
yanak kakis to the counting version if
you're not familiar with it's a
different semi ring it's just so you
write it once you say that because you
you have read this paper and you have I
mean ask yis in the 80s maybe you could
have figured out directly that you can
count but maybe not I mean this I don't
want to debate into it you can do the
yanis for any summing and I agree this
will work I mean I'm not claiming that
this doesn't work but what I'm claiming
is that sometimes you can just take this
compilation algorithm for granted and
then work on some simpler structure this
is what I'm saying this this is just
this I
mean but the the thing that you
mentioned after that is that yes uh the
Drone tree technique forces a true
structure in your circuit that makes
some things not representable in Pol
size typically the answer set of a beta
cyclic negative
conjunctive and and you cannot Escape it
as so somehow the circuit approach is
more General in this
respect I just wanted
to clarify something you said uh that I
said that it is a new insight that we
can
use variable ERS for
factorization this was not what I said I
meant the in
the original paper where Factor
representations were introduced they
used dri and they are variable orders we
just call them variable orders they were
just called dri but it's the same
concept and one can do actually some
restricted form of negation
without growing up the complexity but we
can talk about yeah no you cannot you
can do bet
fora this I have unconditional low BS on
this I me this is for sure but okay I
this is just I was not never clear that
this is this was seen as a variable
order in the original paper this is not
exactly but this is the inside that you
have in the FAQ papers the HR paper I
mean so this this Insight is not new
this is just rephrasing thing in two
circuits okay so we have content for the
discussion later let's thank the speaker
again than